hello everyone we're here at cube con
Barcelona with Dustin Kirkland Dustin is
product manager of gke
Dustin is going to be telling us about
Windows Windows in Google why it's
something that we've heard quite a bit
from customers lately you know those of
us around the linux ecosystem have long
been putting our workloads our
applications into Linux containers and
using kubernetes to orchestrate those
containers until recently that's really
not been available - for Windows
workloads and you know half of the
world's workloads are still developed on
Windows and for for Windows so with the
release of Windows Server 2019 the
Windows Server kernel has built into it
functionality that operates very much
like Linux containers and so in the in
the upstream kubernetes community
Microsoft Google a number of other
companies have been instrumental in
adding support for Windows Server
containers - kubernetes and as of
kubernetes 1.14 the upstream open source
release of kubernetes has declared
windows containers support generally
available very cool so what kind of
features are going to be available in
this release yeah so you should really
think about you know your basic
applications we're focused on largely
first party apps the apps that either
you have the source code to and you
develop yourself on top of Windows or
apps that are being developed new net
apps new visual basic or C++ we see a
lot of in Windows so new apps that can
be can be compiled and build into a
container image we can deploy now
directly to gke as a Windows application
on a Windows node and then you know
importantly we get this question a lot
but yes you can have Windows nodes and
Linux nodes in the same cluster those
pods can communicate you can have
applications a dotnet application
running in a Windows Server container
that's talking to a MySQL service
running in a Linux container that's very
cool so you're gonna have Windows and
Linux coexisting in a single gke cluster
when can customers get their hands on
this yeah so as of gke 114 the
rapid release channel will have the
functionality built into it we're making
that available in an early access
program and we are onboarding our first
customers now we have a sign-up link
that we can send you to to sign up for
that early access we'll run it through
its paces first in early access then an
alpha than a beta and then a ga that's
super exciting while we're looking
forward to that thank you very much
Dustin
[Music]